this is like what I imagine it feels
like to change form as poking off hey
what's going on everybody for first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today were joined by Academy
award-winning actress brie Larson she's
the box-office shattering star you know
from films like Room Captain Marvel and
many more her latest project though is
the brie Larson YouTube channel make
sure to be on the lookout subscribe but
first things first brie Larson the wings
of death
welcome to hot ones hi thank you for
having me
how are you around spicy food like are
you a spicy food person I am a spicy
food person but I feel like today I'm
gonna learn that I'm not that perhaps
what I thought was spicy food was not
spicy at all
[Music]
the classic Fresno ready we're ready
that's fine that's completely fine so
naturally I want to start with your swan
dive into the world of YouTube and I
want to hit you with a hypothetical for
a second okay let's say you're at a
dinner party all right
everyone is pulling up their favorite
YouTube videos and someone passes you
the laptop what are you typing into the
search at that moment it depends I mean
as you've learned I'm pretty um
incapable of a lot of aspects of
technologies who it might be like a
video on like how to turn on your
printer find videos I watched a lot of
vine videos with the start of this
channel I've been even more present
trying to watch so many different
channels and it's such a big world I
mean it's the whole world on one
platform I think for so long my internet
perception I suppose which is where most
people know me from is through like a
press day I always felt like if I
revealed too much about myself that then
people wouldn't be able to believe me as
other characters so that's like been
something that I've always held really
close to my chest and so this is kind of
a way of trying to break out of that
line of thought and say that there's a
lot that people don't know about me and
a lot that I guess deep down I've just
been too scared to be so vulnerable on
the Internet
so that's part of it is I don't know
being more open about wise about who
actually am and not just through like a
director's lens or through the I don't
know the safety of a character
[Music]
so far these taste really good but still
only two men right so far
so far yeah so obviously hot ones has
not been immune to the challenges of
Kovan but the impact on Hollywood has
been massive with movie releases getting
pushed and sets completely shut down
what's one of the more bizarre things
you've heard floated for how to get
productions back on track you know you
read about doing love scenes like as a
totally different part of the production
and then putting that back together in
post and stuff yeah there has been talk
of if there's any sort of contact that
it would have to be CGI and even I think
of it from my understanding even if it
was just like a touch on the arm and he
sort of physical contact would mean that
the actors would have to be in
quarantine for like five days before and
I think tested on either side of it it's
brought from my understanding a lot of
the studios together which is cool so
instead of what was before this
competition of like this versus this
it's like everyone has to kind of talk
together and figure it out together and
share notes so that's pretty cool and
beautiful and I'm a huge proponent of
safety at work so the idea of there
being even more conversations about how
to keep people safe is it's really good
but we'll see see how it goes
[Music]
hmmm interesting different flavor
profile right here like a symphony over
here you know hmm yeah okay I like that
one so I understand that your love of
mushrooms led you to join a mycology
society in Los Angeles where you go out
and learn to forage it's really sweet
are there any fungi 101 basics that you
can teach me right now or is it too
complicated to reduce to tips and tricks
for the internet like you know when you
get like your big screen TV and like the
sour foam that comes with it they're
learning how to grow mushrooms into the
shapes of that so it'd be totally
biodegradable that's really cool
another one is mushrooms have been
really helpful with oil spills they they
basically put down like a layer of hair
and then spores and then more hair and
then it soaks up the oil and then when
they did tests on the mushrooms
afterwards there was no like heavy
metals or anything in it so they
completely purify it's also the first
internet that's also a really cool thing
because you could have a tree fall down
you know miles away in the forest and
mushrooms that are super far away heal
it respond to it and go and decompose
the tree so I think it's just
interesting with all of the things that
humans have invented that we're like
we're geniuses we went to the internet
like no kind of mushrooms kinda did it
first sorry
[Music]
- oh that's gonna be bad you know that's
the thing cuz we've done a couple of
these you know over the Internet and you
know people at home are all like oh you
can't send it to celebrity sauces they
won't they won't sauce the wings right
what I've noticed though is everybody's
just dumping the sauce on their wings
it's actually like harder way art I just
couldn't handle the ten bowls i I
probably I mean if you would have made a
youtube video describing it I probably
would have done it but since you didn't
this is what we're doing okay you don't
taste really good so far
I really like that one it's it's
starting to cook in the end but it does
I got a little throat scratch right
there okay yeah
what makes super mario 3d world as you
put it one of the greatest achievements
in Nintendo history when did I say that
because I feel like I might say that the
new Zelda's kind of top that you got 20
2014 quote yeah
so Nintendo has top itself since then
man I can't blew my mind when it came
out because I had such a deep love for
it in its two-dimensional form I would
have said that seemed quote when Paper
Mario came out when people Mari came out
look this is the greatest achievement I
love illusions and love like optical
illusions I love magic and games that
use that that use I don't know the idea
that there's other worlds other ways of
looking at the world which I think like
Paper Mario and try out the hero really
did yeah
but Nintendo continues to top it so I
mean I'm I'm a deep Nintendo lover
through it through
[Music]
all those calientes Rojo okay here we go
Hiten right this all tastes really good
bottle and
great slackness awesome hey we'll take
it I pre we have a recurring segment on
our cell called explain that Graham
where you do a deep dive on our guests
Instagram poll interesting pictures that
need more context so I'll show you the
picture you just tell me the bigger
story what was your biggest pet peeve
when you were moonlighting as a DJ to
pay the bills early on in your career I
played like I like a Coachella pool
party thing which i think is from the
photo that you're talking about and that
was like a peak that was a peak of this
guy in a shirt that said like [ __ ] swag
that came up and he was like are you
planning on playing anything good he was
like no this is it I don't know what
else to tell you but I will say on the
flip side introducing people to like
obscure music when someone comes up to
me is like what is this and it's like
something that you found from like a
garage sale I was like the best feeling
ever I still have all my records from
that time because I just know I want the
heart to give them up I spent so much
time collecting them here you are with a
Jabba the Hutt I know that you're a Star
Wars obsessive how big a deal was it for
you to score a face-to-face with the
legend that was amazing seeing like any
sort of moment where it's like your
whole life is like you have a separate
thing where it's like I love Star Wars
and Star Wars lives in my TV and then
you get to go in the TV that's just
pretty cool the other thing was I
believe that day was what people don't
know is that was the day that I went in
to get scanned for for them to start
making the Captain Marvel costume so I
was like years before anybody even knew
it was cool because I was able to share
in my excitement of that without giving
away the larger thing like I got to
share in the moment without actually
sharing in the moment
I don't think we'll be able to clear it
so we'll get creative and post but
what's the backstory on how you ended up
in the famous Kardashian family bathroom
selfie at Met Gala oh my gosh
it's careful around the eyes oh yeah
you're right oh ho you're right
oh thank you for looking out for me
today um so the Met Ball bathroom is
pretty notorious it's like where all the
cool kids hang out I had been to mental
I think three times I had never gone to
the bathroom because sometimes people
smoke in there like I know that you're
not supposed to sorry to pull the
curtain back I have asthma so that's
like a number one place I can't go so I
went in for the first time and my goal
was to get in and out of split this
possible and I was trying to hold my
breath as much as I could in there
because I didn't want to deal with the
smoke as I was moving in to wash my
hands and I'm washing my hands and
holding my breath at the same time the
whole thing was just this like wind of
people came in and it was just this like
you're gonna be here like this and they
I know you're going in the picture now
and I was watching me as I was being
squished as I was washing my hands and I
couldn't move I just kept muttering to
myself like oh no oh no oh no like I'm
not supposed to be here it's like you
know all these cool kids and then like I
am not supposed to be in this photo and
also they're all the mannequins but I
couldn't really tell if I was in it or
not there was like one of the people
from the photo turned to me and was like
you need to chill and just be here and I
was like okay and so I like smiled in a
way that was like I'm panicked because I
don't know if I'm in this or not
I am truly here only because I washed my
hands is my publicist gonna be upset
about this like I don't know any of
these people and then I think I mean by
the time I walk back to my chair I was
like who's done it was done I was it was
it had happened and um I don't hate it I
think it's pretty funny
[Music]
oh oh oh hello she has a story she
started off one way and then she turned
on me there's a whole plot arc over here
Wow okay no not go so you've been pretty
vocal about wanting to protect your
anonymity as an actor once explaining to
writer Kate Erland I think it ruins
movies if you know my favorite brand of
potato chip or whatever
does your decision to start a YouTube
channel signify some sort of shift in
that thinking like do you think you're
maybe becoming less guarded in that
respect I would imagine whenever I did
that that article
like I wasn't Captain Marvel it was like
there was a little bit more leeway
between what it was that I was doing and
I made the decision to be Captain Marvel
and I knew what came with that and so
with that it's been a really beautiful
experience actually I would imagine when
I did that article if there had ever
been a paparazzi photo it would have
left me in a full-on panic attack
because it felt so jarring and scary and
exposing and now like honestly like if I
see a paparazzi mic hi and they're like
hi Bri um I it's it's just different for
me now and I've found that whenever I've
read an interview or a biography or
watched a video with an artist that I
love and they're very candid and they're
flawed and I get to see their process I
feel like I'm like oh my god yes like
I'm not the only one who feels like that
and I just started to realize that like
I was being too too self-preservation
'el it's all worth it self-preservation
more than I needed to hobos
still was still really good I
I'm I'm okay still am I
interesting very own brand for me thank
you
okay oh no that was big for of it
maybe wipe some downer or something girl
out it's that bad huh
in this back half it's pretty hot line
up this year
[Music]
it jumped
whoa
yeah
[Music]
and yeah I'm gonna go it up whoa whoa I
enjoyed it
okay
I don't know if I should have done that
but I did it so Bri I understand that
you've been captivated by classic cinema
from an early age sometimes annoying
your mother who'd come home to you
hogging the remote to watch French film
noir in black and white is there a movie
made in the last year or two that you
think will be considered a classic thumb
fifty years from now I think there's a
great chance that portrait of a lady on
fire will be considered classic which
classic movie would you pull off the
shelf for someone who's trying to heal a
broken heart what's coming to mind is
the umbrellas of Cherbourg
but it's like a pretty epic love story
soap honestly nothing matters right now
because this is so spicy
can you suggest a cult classic that's
special to you but maybe won't click
with everyone who watches it oh yeah
that's basically all my favorite movies
um vagabond hey Anya Fargo is I think
one of the most important pieces of
female representation specific to that
period of time isn't also now scenes
from a marriage it's not really a movie
but it was a series that is amazing eyes
are my favorites and then finally what
classic movie would you recommend to an
adrenaline junkie who's never seen
anything outside of the Marvel Universe
an adrenaline junkie like Enter the
Dragon I would consider that a classic
like I don't know how far back we're
going then I think getting into the with
Bruce Lee catalog it's definitely
there's so much so much passion so much
excitement so much harder Street like
wow wow I was just
I've been rewatching some of
is that all right breathe okay yes are
you ready to move on here
this is numb
yeah beyond insanity
how was your digestive system by the way
doing the show like are you compromised
in any way are you I think that I'm I've
permanently become something else
the problem is you know like we've been
taking a break for from production for
these reasons you know it's like now
though I feel like I'm I have to relearn
it all like I'm going through the same
thing like I'm sweating when I usually
don't write well ready ready
Media
[Music]
this is like what I imagine it feels
like to change form as Pokemon so the
Internet as we know it today has become
a tool for character actors I've heard
people talk about you know studying
YouTube videos to get accents down or
when Margot Robbie was on the show she
said that she'd watch it so that she
could understand the reaction of people
when they get electrocuted so this is
relatively new phenomenon oh yeah we're
sure like when I did short term 12
am i different yet I feel like I'm
taking a new form uh
Bertram twelve I would find on like
message boards and things interviews
with people you know they do like asking
any things playing a social worker and
you could get a lot of really great info
I don't know what else is here than the
internet teaches new things
what do you find special about reddit
you once said that it's the only place
where you really enjoy reading the
comments oh yeah I don't feel that way
Freddy became terrible but it was a
helpful tool to me at one point I
remember maybe like eight years ago or
so you're like turn for me and I was
like yeah enough maybe it was less than
six years ago yeah all right brie Larson
two more to go Oh God
ha this is like I said does anyone ever
talk to you about like doing this like
if people could buy the sauces and do
this as like a first date or something
like this feels like a pretty like
intense way of just like get right to it
or like a job interview
maybe that is like just a kit the the
Icebreaker kit just like get to the
baseline okay I can't even like like my
arms are different now like my arms are
like just dug into my legs like I'm
contorted
but you know what you know what a lactam
marvel you're still standing
you're still standing
[Music]
I want to be brave but I'm scared I'll
give my body I'm like hugging myself
[Music]
what do you see is the biggest
difference between fans who recognize
you from Avengers and fans who know you
from short-term 12 right so if it's like
a fan of Captain Marvel it'll usually be
something like go to Marvel captain bar
about like something like yet it kind of
makes me think of like someone shouting
from like far away like they'll want to
like necessarily like say hi but they're
just like yo I did my first look con
experience you there was somebody who
made like a short term 12 like t-shirt
and it's so sweet because that's the
interesting thing about being in movies
are bacon TV it's so different from
being like a stand-up comedian or being
a musician where you're constantly in
the presence of the people that are
consuming the things that you're making
like I'm not unless I go to like a con
or something like that I don't know and
so it's really cool to have that these
shared moments of recognizing with
something that you made that really
mattered to you has you no matter to
them or change them in some way and
you're just not learning about it cool
all right brie Larson
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
but I see you already know the drill oh
[Music]
okay
cheers Cheers
[Music]
okay brie Larson here we are at the end
of her wild spicy wing ride and only one
more bump in the road as we mentioned in
the beginning you're now braving a brand
new world on YouTube so now with your
mouth on fire
let's just talk through some of the
basics okay uh-huh first things first
how are you gonna open each video you
can't say what's J blend J Buhl's that
one's taken by Jack Black um help it's
Bridget um all I can hear in my head
right now so spicy like my inner child
is going help um uh-huh hey yud I have
to have stopped YouTube that's great
that's great number two what are you
gonna call your army of fans brie Larson
errs yeah I think a question do they
name themselves or do I name them really
[ __ ] named themselves finally can you
sign off smash that like
please subscribe you heard her
that's a Larsson speaking the truth and
look at you Bree taken down ten
scorching hot vegan nuggets in the
comfort of your own home now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you Bree this camera or
possibly a camera B if you've set one up
let the people know what you have going
on in your life hi I'm relaxing
I just find it the start a YouTube
channel we're here I feel extreme
presence smash the like or don't just
subscribe like it in subscribing it's
actually a good kind of high like it's
the high that I was talking about like
wine went to that restaurant in India
where you're just kind of like wow what
is life huh what do you do with yourself
after this so you're gonna do try and
like upload everything to Dropbox while
you're still high from your spice hey
what's going on hot ones fans this is
Sean Evans checking in to give you the
origin story behind louis calientes Rojo
so a few months back we decided to go
completely bizarro world and went dr.
Frankenstein on all of our sauces and
and started mixing and matching the
peppers and just put it out thought it'd
be a stupid one-time thing but we
accidentally threw that science
experiment created one of the greatest
sauces of all time lows calientes Rojo
get your bottle at Heat inist Heat nests
com2 get a bottle of los calientes Rojo
lows calientes Rojo accidentally
delicious
[Music]